I'm really honored that you guys both
are here and um to start maybe you guys
could just introduce yourselves and just
say where you're from and uh yeah just
let's start with that well I'm Travis
Irvin I'm from uh East Tennessee
Knoxville uh God's country as we like to
say uh I ran off and joined the Marine
Corps at 18 and that's kind of where my
this story kind of starts okay yeah okay
and how about you
yeah I'm mamad Idris hamar originally
I'm from Afghanistan I was born in Kul
and like I joined with the
Marines U between 2010 11 and that's
what my story just start from there and
and and where did you guys where where
did you guys meet when did you guys meet
we met in Maria Afghanistan in 2010 so
my platoon was pushed out to Maria to uh
continue clearing operations there Maria
at that time and down in Helman Province
was like the last big uh Taliban
stronghold and U you know we don't have
interpreters we've got you know Marines
that'll kind of get punched out to go to
language schools but it's you know it's
such a complex uh language that they're
speaking Dar and P too it's there's not
a lot known about it so you know our
guys can kind of speak words here and
there but we need you know better
linguist with us and so uh the US
government will reach out uh to Afghan
locals that are uh Thor thoroughly
vetted to come work with us and that's
where uh I ran into him and because so
much of what what you're doing over
there is uh you you know in engaging and
trying to gather information find out
who's who and where they're at right
like can you just explain the need for
interpreters and why that is and that it
didn't start off like that and can you
just sort of talk about like your kind
of history with it from what you saw um
you know the language part is huge cuz
we're out running around with guns and
uh you know looking for bombs but you
know there's there's more information we
need we need to talk to locals and
figure out you know what are you seeing
in the morning times what are you seeing
in afternoon and evening times and you
know who's who around this Village and
that's where guys like Rah come in and
you know they can chat these guys up and
gain trust and rapport with them and
yeah they're a key piece of our
operations do you remember when you guys
first met was there anything do you
remember your first impressions of each
other absolutely uh the first time when
I just met
uh my dear brother you know I just call
him my dear brother he is more than than
my blood brother you know uh it was in
marja District of uh app Hilman province
of
Afghanistan uh it was like uh in the
midnight I just like
uh came from another post to their
post uh we just walked like 30 or 45
minutes
uh then we arrived to the post where was
my mission started from that day uh so
in the early morning I just met Travis
and also uh my other team Marines over
there it was the first day I met him
over there and my mission just started
with them from there and and so when
when you guys was that your first was
that the first time you had worked with
Marines or had you already been working
with the Marine it was the first the
first time and what can you just
I I I mean the best way you can I mean
can you kind of like walk me through
where that decision comes from like what
made you want to get to to work with
them and and and you know what was going
on in your life in those days yeah
actually before I joined
Marine
uh since
I I just realize it and I have
experience about my country story you
know I just planned and decided with
myself to be go out outside this country
and just live in a peaceful area you
know not in darkness so just one year
ago when I just joined with Marines I
just start like a I have just met one of
the like a captain he she was my friend
as well she was like uh working with the
US Army uh in loger Province and I was
on that time working for Indio I mean
land government organization on that
time uh so I met her over there and it
was one of my target to start moving and
put the first steps to go to the United
States for higher education and for like
a peaceful life not only for myself for
my uh children future so it was my uh
vision and Target how many kids do you
have uh I have three three kids yes how
old are they
uh my oldest just uh she's eight and I
have a twins boy and girl they four and
a half that's beautiful Crazy Kids yeah
crazy kids crazy kids I love it I love
it and and and like for either one of
you guys like can you just I mean I know
it's a big question but you know I think
for all of us that that that that that
haven't served and haven't been over
there and are just sort of like all our
news is is is filtered In from from
various different parties can you guys
just sort of explain at that time you're
talking about like 2008 2009 correct
like what what what's the state of
Afghanistan like when was the first time
you were over there what what what did
you see in Afghanistan what are the
biggest misconceptions I'd love to hear
about growing up there i' just like to
hear more about it uh common miscon I
remember the first time that I got there
you know that was 2010 I'm young you
know I'm like 20 years old can't even
like you know can't even legally drink
you know but I'm over running around
with a gun and you know and you're
you're so
immature you know at that at that age I
remember before we even got sent to
Afghanistan I knew we were going to
Afghanistan I knew we were going to end
up going to a place called marja and but
I'm so young I didn't even like look
into what Maria even was right you know
right like how easy that would have been
for me to get on the old Google and look
up what this place is and what it looks
like but we didn't even it's like send
us wherever we don't care wherever the
[__] you want to send us yeah totally
you know and we show up over there and
you know marja it's it's down south it's
like the you know a agricultural Hub in
the country and uh I mean it's just
farmland and and poor people that's it
you know you're expecting to see you
know I guess it it was hard for you know
somebody at my age over there what are
we doing over here fighting in this
Farmland surrounded by all these poor
people over here why are there Marines
dying you know and army guys dying every
day like what are we fighting over right
now you know and then you know as the
deployment goes on you know you start to
build relationships in these little
cities and Villages and you see these
little kids running around and you know
they have nothing you know just
absolutely nothing
so uh that was a wild thing for us to
see at that age you know and when and
and when you engage with the Taliban
like when you when when you engage with
You Know The Enemy wh while while you're
there is it I because you hear about it
all the time was it easy for you to sort
of like decipher who was who or were you
were you able to get like Garner some
sort of understanding of what the people
of Maria felt about the Taliban and what
that relationship was uh you know I
think from the the people of Maria you
know from their mindset from what I've
gathered and witness you know they're
just trying to survive you know they
know that Americans aren't going to be
there
forever we know we're not going to be
forever the Taliban knows we're not
going to be there forever so you know
the Taliban really they really pick and
choose on when they're going to show
their face and when they're going to do
an attack and yeah I don't know it's
it's just a wild it's a wild place you
know and it's not like you know the
talibans running around in uniforms that
say Taliban right you know they're
blending in with these villagers and you
don't know who's who you know it's one
day they're you know you think this
guy's your friend and then later on you
know you find out that they're giving up
information to the T they're spotting us
you know they're they're watching us
come out of our little Patrol bases
which I think a lot of people you know
they they think military bases and it's
these giant bases with jets launching
off of them that's not where we were at
I mean we were in somebody's house that
we took over in the middle of the night
and filled sandbags up and made posts in
the middle of the night you know that's
how we're living you know we show up
into a farmers's compound throw them
some money and say you got to get out of
here and there's really no uh separation
from where we're living in the city I
mean we are in the city there's no you
hear that term oh you leave the wire you
know like there's no wire you know um
but you know as we would come out of our
Patrol bases you know we usually run
three operations a day morning afternoon
and night and uh we'd have these little
uh devices that could pick up on their
radio
traffic and uh guys like Rah would be
listening to these
devices and relaying to us okay this is
what they're saying this is where
they're at oh they're planning an attack
here but you can hear them counting us
and calling out where our weapon systems
are oh here's a long rifle over here
here a machine gunner over here you know
and it's crazy to hear that you're like
holy [__] like they're watching us you
know you can't see them and you don't
know who's giving up that information
but you know a lot of times it's
villagers that they'll pay off you know
but so it sounds like an environment
where like trust is so sort of
impossible to kind of how people sort of
feel about you seems Seems enormously
difficult and you know you guys refer to
each other as brothers I mean how does I
I'm really interested in in how trust is
earned and then what's that environment
like is it the same for you is it the
same for folks who who grew up in marer
for for for the the farmers or the
villagers that work there I mean it can
you just talk about trust in that
environment and how it works yeah uh
actually it was so difficult to make it
make them trust as you know so difficult
for those kind of pupils because the
pupils over there they don't have
knowledge they were not like a literate
pupil the schools was closed over there
and they entire
life not only for women's for for the
male generation as well you know so all
of them just grew up with the shovel
with the farming nothing else like that
I mean the villagers and on that area
but it was just Ana I mean Afghan
National Army and the beside of them it
was the Marines you know we just make
trust for them we just had like make
sure you know I mean like big meetings
every week over there all the key
leaders would come from the village to
sit and talk with us and we develop
rapport with them like that yeah we just
like motivate them for democracy we just
motivate them for having peaceful life
and there we want to make them happy
every day than previous of the past so
it was their life and it was that that
they trust us not 100% but a little more
than before and every day we just ging
their trust as much as we can and
meanwhile you're you're trying to earn
the trust of of did you feel like you
had the trust of the Marines that you
were with right off the bat of course
you did feel that you did feel that and
and and and just tell tell me a little
bit more like kind of just whe whether
it's philosophically or like I I
understand I I I guess what you were
saying is that you had this urge you
knew you were dedicated you're an
educated man you're a dedicated man to
your family you knew that eventually
wanted to what you wanted to leave
Afghanistan right when did that feeling
start you know was that was that before
the war like you what did something
change in your life to to to make you
feel that way did did you always know
that you wanted to get out of
Afghanistan yeah exactly since I was
just like seeing my father's life what
was your father's life like uh I mean
just he grew it as human over there you
know he didn't like had higher education
you know he didn't has like own
independence for himself for his family
you know for my grandfather for my
uncles for my aunts for all of his
family so when I was just looking at
them every times it was just like making
me sad so I just decided on that time
with myself to find a way to go out from
here and make a good life change this
did your father want that for you did
your father want you to have a different
life exactly but but my grandfather I
mean they didn't want this for my father
you know so that's why because my father
was my father was like educated person
he was working with defense Ministry and
from since he just born and joined with
the army with the military so he didn't
like uh has any stuff for me to don't go
there or here just he wants me to grow
up in a very peaceful area
like this so on that time I just decided
to start working with the uh like a
private companies because it was that
time the private companies was the way
to go to America or go to the Western
countries for better life you know
that's why I just stepped on on this way
mhm MH yeah c can you sort of remember
your your uh just sort of like your own
personal history
with w w with the Taliban and and and
how you sort of felt that that that the
what sort of the relationship with kind
of like the common the common person in
your country with the Taliban and what
are the pressures to join and and and
how do most folks feel about them there
and and and as they came into Power did
something change drastically in the
country and if so do you remember is
there any memories of that uh yeah
actually in the first time when they
just got our country
I mean it was like
1990 or 1992 I think so this years when
they just got and handed over our
country I was a kid but still I remember
some memories from that time you know
that they were just stoning the pupil
stoning the wom's you know stoning
stoning yeah and also they just killed
you know they just killed the pupils
like in front of the eyes of the pupils
you know they just gathered the pupils
they just announced it in the radio
there was no other television on that
time they just announced in the radio
that we have like hanging you know how
old were you when that happened uh I was
like
maybe
14 I can say or maybe 13 but still I
remember that you know it was big
stadium in cabble just closed by the
presidential Palace closed by so it was
like crazy time on on that time you know
and you ask it what what why they just
killed this people you know for nothing
they just killed innocent
people and and I mean I he I mean so it
was I'm so sorry so it was all that that
changed my mind to just evacuate from
this country as soon as you can even
just recently I mean in the recent years
I had special life over there I had my
own business my own company everything
but I left behind
everything because I didn't see any
bright future for my children for my
family this this brutality and
uh like you say this sort of like
meaningless brutality do you remember
the first time you either witnessed that
or or something that kind of defined
them to you or or or the first thing
that you heard or that you saw over
there that that that showed you kind of
that that that Define the ethos of those
people
um you know I think the my first like
experience like holy [__] we're at War
now you know is when you see a guy that
you know that you drank beer with and
hang out with blown up you know and his
body's ripped in
half you know and this is a good guy you
know or another guy that's been shot you
know and killed you know you seeing your
buddies dead you know running them to
helicopters you know that's that's like
the this is real moment you know and
just the brutality that you know these
the the Taliban would do you know they
would go out to these Farmland that were
in and and just plant IEDs everywhere
all over the fields and you know kids
would step on them all the time you know
innocent people would just walk along
you know and step and step on these
devices Taliban doesn't care yeah
they're after us at the end of the day
but they're putting them in this this
family's backyard you know eventually
one of these kids is going to step on
this or some guy on a tractor plowing
his field is going to you know hit this
IED and that's when it's like for real
you know it's
like seeing little kids suffering you
know I did a little stint after my my
time with the uh Marine Corps I got a
job with National Geographic and I I
went back to Afghanistan and kind of got
to see the war from a from a non you
know infantrymen grunt view you know cuz
in the in the grunt once it's this this
is what you see you know you're you're
you got your mission is you don't
understand where these helicopters are
coming from or where you're sending your
wounded off to you don't you don't see
it at all U but with the that job you
know I got to take a step back and kind
of be a spectator in war and kind of see
okay here's where the fighter pilots are
taken off from here's the uh Logistics
side of the house here's the helicopters
and then I did a little time in a
Frontline Hospital uh it was called a
shock trauma platoon and we just sat in
this tent for you know a month two
months periodically in and out for a
month two months and man the casualties
just keep coming in you know and it's
just like holy [__] I remember I had
never like cried you know the unit that
we were with we lost 15
guys you know 15 guys killed which is
[__] crazy and so I remember the
Purple Heart ceremony after we came back
I mean there was a hundred people lined
up in a formation there were so many
purple hearts handed out that they
didn't do it like individually you know
like okay this person got shot this and
that okay next guy we're going to read
off there were so many people that they
just did it all at once wow you know but
anyway so to be in this uh and I had
never shed a tear over it really hadn't
you know lost some really close friends
and when I you know a year later I went
back with that Nat Geo job and I'm
sitting in this uh this tent and the you
know income the casualties and here my
dumbass is with a camera running around
filming it cuz I want people to
understand what's going on over there
you know but you really feel like a
piece of [__] running around filming
this dude with a gunshot wound in his
forehead you know you're just that's
just unreal but I remember this there
was a marine that came in and he was on
an early morning Patrol and uh he was
the radio man and he had a radio antenna
sticking out of his uh
backpack and there's a lot of ungrounded
wires over there and this guy's
patrolling around and and His Radio wire
hit one of these ungrounded wires and it
electrocuted it him and
uh you know they his his unit they call
in the medac birds uh they're called
dust off great guys Blackhawks come in
Snatch this guy up bring him back to the
little tent that I'm at you know filming
these casualties and interviewing
surgeons and stuff like that and uh in
comes this guy and he's back in the day
we' put the radio mic like in between
our Kevlar you know we got our helmet
and you got the strap well the radio
guys would run these run the hand mic up
in here anyway they bring this guy in
and this hand mic is melted into his
face and I remember watching this dude
like nobody knows what's going on over
here you know I remember when we were
there no one no one really ask questions
you know it's like oh you were in
Afghanistan you know everybody's so
desensitized because we've been over
there for 20 years you know they were
like oh yeah it's just War you know this
isn't normal being somewhere for 20
years you know but yeah that was that
that incident when I I saw that dude and
all my buddies that I was with them
wrinkled they'll make fun of me for
telling the story and saying that I
cried but it's it's the truth I mean I I
filmed this dude they tried to
resuscitate this guy for 15 20 minutes
and then finally everybody in the room
agreed they're they're calling it and I
remember I you know turned the record
button off went outside and cried like a
[__] yeah cried like a [__] and this
old crusty surgeon came out he used to
be an 8 8404 Corman that used to run
with the grunts but now he's kind of
leveled up and he's doing bigger and
better things but he came out and he
little tiny guy came out and put his arm
around me and just I'd never met that
dude in my life but he knew you know
where you were at yeah yeah yeah because
when you see you know journalists I was
technically a journalist over there at
that time they're like oh who's this
journalist they have no idea what's
going on but and some people ask about
my background and stuff like that but
you know not a lot of people knew that I
was a part of that as well the year
prior you know my unit had lost 15 dudes
in that same AO that they're
in but yeah that was like a just a
Unreal
like I I'll never forget that so it's
like you you you both and I hate to I
hate to stay on it too much but but but
I mean you both are sort of describing
this kind of chaotic wild environment
that just doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense and this is like this is your home
you grew up in it I mean for for you do
you remember that when you first sort of
had that thought like what the hell is
going on here and and I'm just really
interested in like why maybe your
reasons for wanting to sign up like your
reason for for for wanting to to enlist
and and and then you know um just kind
of your journey through through through
through then being there and and and and
what you saw and what your feelings are
and and and your sort of understanding
that either grew or your lack of
understanding uh I think my story with
wanting to go over there kind of or
wanting to go the military route started
young with me I I was a part of this
program called the Breakaway program uh
where they'd send like court ordered
kids out to the woods to you know get
their asses kicked in you got in trouble
no I didn't I was like a student staff
and my f my parents ran with the staff
that did all outdoorsy mountain men type
people really shaped who I am and and my
values and I really saw the benefit of
uh going out to a shitty place and
living with nothing and having you know
only having the guys around you I really
saw the benefit of that at a young age
and pushing yourself to that at a young
age and uh and also you know September
11th you know I uh I was never allowed
to miss school ever like my parents are
like you're going to school we don't
care if you've got covid right you're
going yeah uh I come from a big family
there's five kids in my family all
together uh but on September 11th my
older uh sibling or no one of my younger
brothers had to go to the doctor so
eenie meeny miny mo I'm staying home to
watch the youngest so I'm sitting at
home on the couch watching I was in
seventh grade so I think 12 13 years old
and I'm sitting on the couch and then uh
watching uh Sports Center you know big
baseball guy sure catching up on I'm
like this is nice I'm hanging out no
school today holiday yeah and uh the
phone rings and it's my dad and he's
like turn on the TV right now and I flip
the you know flip on the news and uh you
know five six seven minutes later we see
the uh the second plane hit the tower um
and that was a pivotal moment for me at
such a young age was like how dare these
[__] you know and I had a
connection with you know I grew up in
Tennessee but you know during the
Summers I'd go you know up to New Jersey
my grandparents had a beach house there
and uh like on the
ocean on Long Beach Island and a lot of
these people running around there were
you know uh firefighters from New York
City and NYPD and sure so it was like
how how dare these people do this but
you know and it sounds corny and this
and that but I knew at that at that age
like this is what I'm doing and I
remember being so [__] pissed that I
was not young enough to to to sign up
right then like I remember being livid
and like counting down the clock like
when I turn 18 years old or when I can
sign this contract I'm going yeah and I
remember being afraid I was going to
miss the war a lot of guys you know say
that too you know it's like I need to
get in the pipeline right away with a
rifle in my hand to go see these dudes
on the front lines as soon as possible
do you remember do you remember where
you were do you remember where you were
with 9/11 or do you remember your first
sort of like understanding of it or or
did did it affect your life yeah on that
time I was like very young boy you know
and also we didn't have any access on
internet on television no television
nothing else we we even didn't have like
electricity you know so but uh the older
people I mean my dad uncle and other
people
they were just hearing the news from BBC
you know and the radio and they were
talking on that time that like a
incident happened to the Trade Center in
the New York in America that the tourist
groups h a that by the al-Qaeda like
this on that time I was hearing all of
these but I was so kid I didn't care
about it so much and I didn't have
knowledge about that so yeah I remember
that just short thing like that but but
but but in in Afghanistan at the time
you know was there a general feeling I
mean when you're when you know at these
big soccer stadiums there are these huge
executions and there's this group that
has taken over and there they're they're
they're ruling with brutality and now
you know that you know somebody somebody
came and and and poked the bear of
America now now now America is getting
involved in some way was there a feeling
in a Afghanistan that this could
potentially come to us or touch us like
would people have any idea of that or or
or no yeah definitely like I said pupils
were just talking about that and had
like feeling you know for the pupils you
know why this like happened what's wrong
with that you know but since most of the
pupils like you don't you know uh they
were not like uh have the outside or I
can say for you like a knowledge of
exterior countries uh to know what's
happening over there you know or what's
going on over there that's why they were
not like uh have like deep feeling
what's happening or they didn't see
anything by television you know by the
TV to see what happened with this people
you know but of course yeah they had
like feeling and talking about that on
that time yeah you know I think seeing
over there these these these people on
the day-to-day they don't have time for
like conversational like gossip of
what's going on they're trying to like
feed their kids in a country where
there's no jobs and trying to scrap B
borrow steel to get their kids fed you
know like they don't have time to like
sit around and you know scroll the
internet and what's going on
philosophize yeah like they're like dude
I got to feed my kids you know and
they're just scraping by all means
necessary by any means necessary they'll
do it and you know I don't fault from
that that's right cuz what would I do to
feed my family and his kids and my loved
ones and and people around my circle I
would do anything you know to do it when
you first get there were you were you
able to make any sense of anything or
like you said it's just this grunt
mentality just like follow Waters one
one foot in front of the other I
remember we flew in we were at a big
base called leatherneck and they're like
you know we we get our briefs from the
metac units are going to be supporting
us hey guys this is how you load your
casualties in uh this is what we're
seeing in the area these are the tactics
that they're using watch out for IEDs
here watch out from there there you know
they're just they put them in everything
from roadkill to the curb to trees to
above you you know they're just so we're
getting schooled up on that and then
they load us on helicopters and we're
like all right we're going to go get
some right now and we're going to go
replace a unit that's there there was a
unit called Third Battalion six marines
that was there they did the initial push
in there and gain the foothold and then
here we come in to replace him and then
they they punch out and go home uh but
we landed on this uh it was a bigger
base in Maria it was called uh like uh
Hansen I think right Hansen yeah cop
Hansen it was called and then uh we land
and then you know it's so loud and
chaotic and dust is flying everywhere
and we we run off the bird and then the
bird takes off and then it's like quiet
you don't hear anything and I remember
you could hear gunfights going on
outside you know because that base were
on was like the big Battalion level
that's where our Battalion commanders
are at there's like nice little Chow
Halls they're living it up you know
in CS and you know they got nice stuff
and then we hear these gunfights going
on where we're going because we're going
to go take over one of these
houses uh and I remember there was a a
and it's Villages like the gunfights are
coming from it's not mountainous right
no no it's straight Farmland swampy
Cotton Fields weed opium uh corn
watermelon you know agricultural uh
stuff uh difficult to operate in um but
yeah remember we we're hearing all this
going on they're like what's going on
out there cuz that's my first you know
I'd been to Iraq before I went to radi
uh Iraq back in uh
2008 and we spent seven months there
just waiting for something to happen and
never did you know as a grunt if you're
not getting after it you're like dude
this sucks you know and your chain of
commands [__] with you you know
trying to keep you busy and keep you mad
you know and and I remember wishing for
that God I just want this gunfight well
fast forward to Afghanistan in 2010 we
land on that base and and then what's
this gunfight going on and it's like oh
you guys are going there the unit you're
replacing the platoon you're rep that's
them right yeah and if I remember
correctly that was the day that a a Hilo
was shot down I want to say it was like
a uh a cobra I want to say but don't
don't quote me on it but there was a
Hilo that was shot down out there in our
battle space and at 2010 in the time you
don't hear of helicop us American
helicopters being shot down so we're
like what the [__] is this place we're
going to so they load us up and we get a
little brief
and then they load us up in like a seven
ton it's called it's a big transport
truck for you know people and they they
drive us out there and we get off and uh
we get to this patrol base right as that
uh Squad is coming back in from that
gunfight and I remember looking at these
dudes and they they look like something
straight out of Vietnam here we are
fresh cams all of our gears good you
know we got the civilian weight we're
carrying from the States you know we're
not Patrol ready you know uh but yeah I
remember them coming back in and they
look like they were just you know in a
gunfight and they were you know sweaty
rocking bandanas not blousing their
boots cuffing their sleeves we don't
care about military regulation and
haircuts dudes with Mohawks and you're
like dude this is awesome like this is
where I want to be right now we finally
like reached this place and so they took
the uh for the next like two or three
days they took the key leaders uh from
our platoon that's replacing this
platoon they took like the platoon
sergeants uh Lieutenant Squad leaders
and team leaders and I was a team leader
at the time and they they took us out on
patrol with those guys kind of like a
left seat right seat with them and
there's no vehicles uh we're all
everything's on foot wow um and so we
start they start integrating us into
their patrols on how what's going on and
they're giving tips and you know don't
cross here cross here little things to
look for and we're just trying to like
soak it all trying to soak cuz we know
is it is it possible to soak it all in I
mean you feel like like how much are you
retaining on on that first you know I
think you're in a a survival situation
so your brain is on like Max overload to
try and retain every but I remember just
being like a we call it a [__] gear
bomb you know there's like a way to
patrol in margia and there's you know
there there's what the States you know
patrolling around in North Carolina
teaches you I got to have all this gear
I got to have all this I need this I
need water you know but when you're
patrolling on foot miles and miles it
comes down to weight you're stripping
all sorts of weight uh learning how to
wear your night vision correctly learn
how to you know use your thermal scopes
and and pec 15s with your lasers on them
and there's there's a there's a massive
learning curve that you're sure that
you're you're battling sure and you
don't want to look like a piece of [__]
either you know it's like you got Junior
guys looking at you you can't seem like
you're iffy about
something it's probably pretty
impossible to not be iffy especially in
the beginning absolutely yeah like
you're you're you're making it up I mean
you're drinking out of a fire hose right
you know right dudes are getting shot
you're hearing about all their dudes
that were killed and shot and maimed
from IEDs and uh you know your biggest
fear is just letting somebody down
behind you you know not seeing an IED
the dude behind you steps on it or and
so it's really that night I mean it's
like first night in it's like you're
like okay this is this is going to be
different this is this is this is wild
this makes and do you remember your
first sort of exposure to the villagers
and like is there any is there any kind
of feeling or to to just the Nationals
in general is there any like what do
they think of me or like I guess what
you guys both describe is there's and
and so many of the folks that that I've
had the honor to talk to have just
talked about this one your every step
you take there could be an IID plus any
person you see could be Friend or Foe
and there's really no way it's very very
hard to figure that out so I imagine
that's just an environment of just
complete and utter chaos and again such
a where we're eventually going to get to
such a difficult environment to achieve
you know real trust and real camaraderie
with with with people that were born in
different places yeah you know I had
never had any exposure to really the
outside of the US before I I don't think
I'd ever talked to somebody from another
country other than a a woman that my mom
uh would go get her nails done at this
little Vietnamese shop and my mom helped
this lady study for you know her uh
citizenship test and I think that was my
only wow if I remember correctly that
was like the only exposure i' I'd had
trying to communicate with somebody who
didn't speak English right out of the
gate wow uh but yeah so we we roll in
there and I think my first exposure to
an Afghan is the uh Afghan Army that
we're kind of paired up with they got
they sent a couple Afghan Army squads to
patrol around with our squads because
we're trying to teach them what's going
on here and this is how you you know
take care of your country this is how
you gain Security in your country do
what we do so communicating with them
and teaching them our tactics and which
was man was difficult and and was a hell
of a thing thing to ask looking back at
it for a bunch of 19 20 21 year old kids
to do you know that's kind of a Green
Beret Special Forces thing you know
those green ber get in and they uh
create networks and they know how to
talk to people and befriend people and
then you know that's the whole Green
Beret Mission you know other than going
out smoke checking dudes right their
mission is to go in there and make
friends somewhere right well asking a
grunt unit to go do that it's like tring
plus you're not I mean like making
friends is not
that's like the time for talking's over
you know um but yeah we would like teach
these guys okay this is how you wear
your gear this is how you make a little
brief a little premission brief when we
go on patrol you're going to go left
we're going to go right uh we're when we
hit this you know building up here we'll
button hook right and we'll link up with
you guys over you know there's a lot of
complex stuff and you're worried about
you always should know where your people
are out on patrol because everybody's
running around with guns I don't want to
end up shooting my guys over here
getting spooked cuz everybody's trigger
happy sure you know everybody's ready to
pull the trigger you know cuz you know
in war there's a clear hold and build
phase can you can you explain that uh I
mean I think don't quote me on this but
I I don't remember what you know army or
or military genius figured this out
there's a clear hold and build phase
well a clear phase is the enemy is still
here and operating freely we need to
clear this whole place out and then
we're going to hold it make sure
everything's good to go and then we're
going to start to rebuild start to
rebuild schools hospitals roads all of
this well we're still in the clear phase
right right you know
so but yeah I remember you know linking
up with these Afghan army guys and we'
create these little terrain models as
best as we could like okay you guys are
going to go this way we're going to go
this way and I remember I don't know it
was probably our 10th Patrol with them
we we punched out and we've got
nicknames for all these Afghan army guys
I remember this Afghan army guy we
called love seat like you would sit on
you know for whatever reason we called
him love seat and he had had an M249 saw
which is like a squad automatic weapon
and we punch out and man we're not 10
minutes outside of the gate and this
dude is just unloading on us yeah just
and we we hit the dirt like what the
[__] is you knew it was him oh yeah yeah
cuz I know where they're at you know I'm
watching them you know but yeah know
you're just trying to get these guys on
the same page as you yeah yeah but that
would happen like all the time oh my
gosh yeah and and and and and from your
perspective uh how did everybody take
sort of your decision to work with the
Americans was there any resistance to
that were people supportive of it in
your
life uh actually my family especially my
dad and my mom was with me in the first
but uh after just I just was six months
in the mission they just heed you know
on TV as well at the same time in the
newspaper everything in the media
the interpreters were killing every day
animation every single like this you
know so my dad my mom was so worry and
has concern on this you know so when I
just actually the interpretors over
there in the post on the mission didn't
have access on the phone to talk with
their family because we didn't have
access on this you know there was no
antenna I mean zal to talk with your
family but I have access but by the
helps of my Marines you know with the
satellite I just talk with my family via
that and my just my dad just told me
please please come back please come back
stop this like this but I didn't give up
you know myself so even my first unit I
mean Travis and with other people just
left over there I was over there I just
continue my mission just for more than
three more months then I just received
my paperwork work and come back home for
a holiday to process all this paperwork
to get to the US like this you know when
I just get back to home so my dad my mom
just stopped me and just cried please if
you're like my our son please don't go
back to the mission you will you would
be killed interpreters were being sought
out it was especially dangerous to be an
interpreter Patrol interpreters are
getting killed cuz they're out walking
around in the same minefields we are
they're in the same gunfights we are so
they're definitely a part of those
casualty counts but also when they would
go back to visit their family or go back
on vacation you know there there's an
entire alqaeda and Taliban intelligence
cells out looking for the these people
you know I think a common misconception
about the Taliban and Al-Qaeda they're
just a bunch of dudes living in caves
they're not really up to date on
technology man they they evolve they've
evolved over the past 20 years and
they're you know they're they're they
they know what they're doing they know
how to find these people and you never
know who's secure with information
because you know his information is
sitting at an embassy or or or office
somewhere that's supporting government
operations well who's to say that a
Taliban dude isn't working in there that
can now give up that information for the
right price and now they know you know
where his Homer record is
andu [__] yeah it's real to this day and
and did that make you worry that that
you were potentially putting your your
mom and dad's life in danger that that
they absolutely absolutely that's why I
just didn't go back to Mission but I
just I just start searching another job
I just start working on after that with
the US Army corpse of Engineers you know
in the Cobble in the city with a private
Construction Company who was just
working on behalf of that US Army corpse
of Engineers we were just building make
the HQ I mean headquarters for the
Afghan National Police A&P and also aan
National Army like this so but I just
continue keep going my working and my
task only just alongside with the US you
know whole my life yeah I remember we'd
get pushed we'd get pushed in
interpreters out to us you know and we
run through them you know some guys
would get out there man they just
weren't a good fit you know why they
they couldn't you know show up on time
for patrol they couldn't wear their gear
they they'd forget their night vision
goggles and it's like man we don't have
time to hold anybody's hands either
you're you know about this and you're
going to put in the time to be ready or
you're out of here and sometimes guys
would show up and they'd go on that
first Patrol with us and they'd get into
a gunfight and they're like I'm out of
here never again yeah yeah I remember
ROM telling me when he got the job being
an interpreter you know he had to take
like a a basic English test like can
this guy actually speak English and
translate and um he was saying that they
you know they sent him to the airport to
fly down to Maria well he had no idea
that he was going to be fighting like
we're fighting you know so he shows up
with us and sees like a bunch of dudes
with Mohawks and Cami pain and dirty and
you know there's no showers or toilets
or Chow halls or we're eating out of
bags and you know but he you know he
stayed you know which says a lot about
him absolutely yeah he stayed it was
really difficult for me you know like
for a middle city boy just move out for
from his home you know we we can say for
this like milk boy you know milk boy
yeah so just from his home yeah live
left behind his family yeah just go to
war you know War yeah we we gear see the
rifle just uh see himself in the middle
of the gunfight Fields you know gunfight
it was difficult for me I bet but as
Travis it I just stay yeah yeah yeah you
made a name for himself did you
recognize how special he was and did
that Brotherhood begin because you saw
how difficult it was for him in the
beginning and that he didn't and then
was it the choice to stay and come back
and not run you know I don't think that
you know at that age and with all of
that going on your brain doesn't really
process what's going on you don't get to
pick who you're with you don't get to
pick who your machine gunner is the
Marine Corps decides everything for you
everything you know you just you're just
so used to saying all right Roger we're
going to roll with it yeah uh but you
know once I you know started to get the
you know like as I said I got the job
with National Geographic and and really
got to step back and see this war from a
you know a different perspective you
know you you really start to reflect on
the relationships that you made and
like uh yeah I mean this guy stuck it
out with it he was one of us you know he
was in all the gunfights we were in he
he he was promised by the government to
hey man you stick your time out with us
we're going to get you out of this
country this is the
deal and and once I realized that you
know that wasn't happening for him that
really weighed on me for a long time and
I realized realized that was happening
in like 2012 time frame and I remember a
time with him where I felt like I turned
my back on him uh when I got that job
with National Geographic I went down my
contact list you know on Facebook and
and and U and I remember scrolling
across his name we'd been in
communication and I deleted him off
Facebook you know because it was like
What if I get rolled up here by the
Taliban out here cuz I'm now I'm a
civilian over there right I don't have
the protection of a squad of dudes
around me right so if I get rolled up on
they take my phone and then they start
looking through my cont okay who who's
he friends with I'm friends with this
dude now they can come after him but you
know I did it for his own protection but
still you know it's something that I
never you know forgive myself for H you
know and and I and I always waited over
the years man and just would stay up at
night thinking about it since 2010 to
2021 when he when he finally made it
over here like waiting for an
opportunity to make it happen for him
and and and were you you guys how how
did you guys communicate during that
time uh once I wrapped that job with Nat
goo I you know added him back on
Facebook and we talked and strategized
and he would send me paperwork and ask
questions and you know we would we just
two idiots trying to figure out how to
navigate this immigration system that's
a part of America right now sure you
know we we don't have the word grunts
you know it's like I don't know I'm not
a lawyer right you know it's extremely
difficult and backed up and you know
also I was you know working with the
government uh doing private security
work with the government I can't be
friends with you
know uh people that aren't Americans you
know you can but it man it'll it'll give
you some trouble when it comes to get
like you know time for security
clearances and stuff and like that
um but yeah that always weighed heavily
on me that man there's something that I
could be doing more I'm ignoring this
guy like um but in my brain like I swear
in my head like I always knew that we
would get something it it's going to
happen it's going to get done you know
we just need that just a little sliver
of opportunity and we're going to take
it did did you develop a a hatred for
for Al-Qaeda did you did you develop a
hatred for the Taliban 100% how common
is that in your country do most people
feel that way most of them yes majority
of people had the same feeling the hats
from them yeah right yeah I can tell for
you like since I born I was born over
there and I just grow up and I just like
knew my right my left hands I just had
like a diff difficult life over there I
was so interested to have like higher
education but I couldn't because of
economic situation over there at the
same time because of this politician
system which running on that country
since the beginning until now you know
but I was trying myself you know to be
educated person I'm I'm still not
educated person but I just tried my best
you know on that time I my dad was like
very we have like a very
poor uh life you know we were rented
house on that time the computer was like
there was no computer actually commonly
in the homes I mean private computers no
people had that one all of the people
just going to this special Co courses
private courses private schools to learn
computers like this so I start I I even
didn't have money to go to learn
computer you know in private schools so
my dad just like borrow it money you
know borrowed money for me to just go
and learn this since you like this you
know when I just came back home I didn't
have any computer at home so I just draw
you know I just draw with the charcoal
you know the keyboard wow the keyboard
of a computer just like uh close by the
miror of the I mean to close by window
you know just I draw draw up by the
charcoal and I just learn a typing from
that I just I just like uh imagine that
the the miror the window in front of me
is like a screen of computer and the
keyboard just under my hands which I
draw it by the charcoal is the real
computer wow he can type better than me
now wow so I learned the computer by
this way you know so that's why that's
why this made me this made me to make
decision to take out your children to
other country or take out yourself to
other country to behave not like
this yeah you know I think when the West
came into Afghanistan and you know
there's a common misconception that it
was just Americans there I mean all of
like NATO is there you know they don't
they're they're not involved fully like
we are but they're there you know so
with the West coming Technology's coming
and and it's advancing and you know
computer they're starting to be more
computers internet service cell phones
smartphones and I think the Afghan
people they start to see what's going on
outside these borders and they're seeing
the rest of the the world and I think
for a lot of them guys like Ron like oh
it doesn't have to be like we're living
here we're like the only you know
there's very few countries living like
we are right now yeah yeah and and you
know and if you look at you know what
the the talian doesn't want internet and
they don't want their people to see the
outside world they don't want them to
have a taste of it you know because then
that'll start you know causing that
little flame in somebody do you guys
have any insight or opinions on what's
driving them I mean besides I mean I
think the misconception for a Layman
like me is it's just it's all this sort
of like fanatical yeah I think it's just
their interpretation of the Quran Rah
you could probably speak on better on it
than me just like the just like the
Bible that Christians look at you know
there's so many different
interpretations of it it's just that
their interpretation of the Quran
happens to be you know some pretty uh
wild extremist views you know they are
against Quran you know they are against
that because in Quran it's not saying
like that's what they are doing right
now you know they put all the pupils in
the cage you know they are just want
their own power running the country and
doing everything for themsel and also
they
do some activities that Not a Human
Being do that you know not I mean not
only Quran not a human wants to do that
they're not human they don't deserve to
say they are human they are wild animals
mhm yeah anybody that'll weaponize a
child and load a child up with
explosives and tell them to go into this
building and blow themselves up I mean
what kind of psychopath do you have to
be you know and I think you know
convincing people to to do that comes
from not being educated and being able
to manipulate these people in the name
of God sure you know they they weap they
weapon us this like a business for their
own targets sure when we ultimately
withdrew and H how how did you feel
about it how did that sit with you and
and um you know just what's your take on
that um I mean it was just we knew we're
not going to stay there forever you know
we we can't just take over this country
so we know we're going to leave um but
you know after you spend 20 years in a
country thousands of our dudes die men
and women are dying you you would think
that
the I don't know the uh result would
have been better than what it was um you
know like for instance when I was in
when we were in Maria and we were in
another place called sangan you know
where I mean just hundreds of Marines
and you know army dudes died there but I
remember going back here I am again
referencing this Nat Geo job but went
back with Nat Geo and I got to see these
same battle spaces that we were in we
were patrolling well now I'm back as a
civilian and we get to see these
places and and there and it's in Taliban
control you know like a year later two
years later what do we why what was all
that worth if we're just willing to
leave you know because they it goes back
to that clear hold build phase well we
did the clear phase where was the hold
and build you know where where was that
if that was your great idea where was
that and why was that worth sacrificing
a bunch of 19 20y old kids cuz that's
who's dying make no mistake you know it
is a bunch of kids over there dying why
wasn't that
held I think that we set up the Afghan
Army um now they they could have done a
thousand things better no doubt but you
know we kept the the war going on the
American side through massive air bases
that are over there you know you got
Camp leather their neck Bastion uh
Kandahar Airfield uh jbad uh you know up
in Cobble there's bases everywhere that
are run an aircraft out to places like
margin saying to resupply us you know
with you know beans bullets
Band-Aids um when we left you know the
the Afghan Army didn't have that ability
to resupply themselves right and the
whole time we're over there telling the
Afghans look this is how you do it this
is how you Patrol this is how you and
it's like okay but how do you resupply
and that's something in my opinion was
never really focused on with the Afghans
you know they can't resupply themselves
they're out here in these remote Patrol
bases the closest person's 50 mil away
you know they're getting overrun and
they did all the time those Patrol bases
that we handed over to those Afghans
were overrun all the time you know
they'd either run out of rounds or you
know take five rounds with them and take
their uniforms often leave you know but
we set them up uh for I'm not going to
say we set them up for failure but they
can't resupply themselves so how are
they going to survive and once they left
or or or once you went to the core of
engineers are you worried for your
safety every day exactly and and what's
that like I mean like how how many
people in your life know I mean how how
common was it that you know ex
interpreters were being hunted down yeah
yeah yeah I can I can tell you there are
there are right now you know you can
search in Google there are a lot of
repors killed since American left over
there I mean not in this last two years
even on that time you know in the
previous government you know they just
have access especially outside when you
just walked outside of the Cobble you
know from the capital they had the
talian were present on that time you
know when they just captured the pupils
they have especially I mean the
biometric system with yourself they just
puted your fingers on that and all of
your data will just
appear for them and they just know
recognize you that this guy work for the
Americans as
interpreter not only interpretors also
they just killed many like I can tell
you thousands of an I mean Afghan
National Army the same time yeah would
just line them up and execute them yeah
because interpretors and Afghan National
Army had biometric you know can you
explain that what what's the biometric
it's a kind of like ice ice screening
also the fingers you know so when you
when they just puted your fingers on
their machines small machines and also
your eyes it's just appeared that this
guy is working with the government or
alongside with the US Army so in this
reason I yes I had concern every day I
was suffer for this so if this happened
for me what should my children do yeah
there's a vetting process that takes
place when guys like Rah come to work
with us in Afghan Army you know I'm G to
make you look at me and I'm going to
take a picture of you're this crazy
science fiction machine that takes
pictures of your retina and your
fingerprints well eventually where's
that information going to end up you
know for instance like when the country
collaps where did all that go yeah well
it goes into the hands of the new regime
they have everything from helicopters to
guns to night vision to all of our
allies information wow and that's how
it's being that's how these guys are
being hunted did that hit you
immediately like that that that that
that he was in
danger yeah I mean I I knew it since we
left there in 2010 and uh or 2011 when
we left you know like I we we all kind
of anticipated that eventually would end
badly but never to the uh extent that it
did never did I think that we would
leave guys like Rah over there you know
I I would at least think we would like
expedite their uh immigration process to
get them out you know I mean [__] they
were on the front lines with us right
you know so never did I ever expect that
it would go down like it did and I don't
know how familiar you are yeah would
love well I mean I'd love for you to
walk me through it um but just the you
know there was a basically a meeting
between the US and I'm paraphrasing here
but there's a meeting that takes place
between the US government uh and the
Taliban saying okay we're out of here
yep we want you to give us a little bit
of time but we're going to get out of
here and the taliban's Very firm on you
guys are going to be out by this date
you know and now it's public okay
Americans are out it's hitting the news
everybody you know news channnel are
pouring into the country to try and
because the taliban's coming you know
and before they took over cble I mean
you know Taliban you know Afghanistan
looks like this they're taking over
cities and provinces and they're coming
in and they're going to close on the
capital Cobble and then you know
Afghanistan's going to be the talibans
again but you know from a strategic
standpoint and I'm no General right but
why would you take away the giant air
bases that were the spine of the War for
America right you know jbad Kandahar
leatherneck Bastion go down the line of
these giant air bases that kept us
afloat for 20 years uh why would you
take those away in the middle of an
evacuation you know you know I think a
lot of times with the cluster [__] that
the evacuation was you know you you hear
the politician say oh well we evacuated
100,000 people you know 100 th that's
the largest air evacuation in the
history of uh probably the world and
it's like well if you were
willing to evacuate 100,000 people like
that without vetting these people really
figuring out who they are you know why
didn't you do that for the past 20 years
right right what why did you have to
bring it down to like it was like the
the wire I mean the amount of people
specifically kids that were killed
outside that airport in Cobell was is is
unfathomable you know and and US
military you know 13 US service members
got killed by a suicide attack in my
opinion keep these bases around and then
okay you you're going to Evac people
people okay cool Roger that you guys you
know drug your feet on it but all right
maybe start flying them to these other
bases where we've got a great standoff
where we're not going to get hit with
rockets and gunfire where you look at
the airport and Cobble the Taliban are
literally holding hands with Marines
basically not actually holding hands but
I mean they're from here to you we've
been fighting these guys for 20 years
and I'm watching on TV there's a
19-year-old kid with an M4 standing
right next to a Taliban dude and you're
like what is going on here right now
what is happening yeah so it was a
cluster [__] and and what was that time
like from your perspective I mean is it
you're just doing whatever you can to
get out uh actually I wasn't in Kabul on
that time when the country fell back
into the hands of them I mean Taliban I
was in stumble for a business trip at
the same time I was trying to gain a
Visa for my family I mean before collaps
the country I was tried four times for
my family to get a Visa turkey Visa to
move them to that country to live over
there and where was your family in
kabble yeah in kabble so I was in stul
when the country just collapsed and my
family just stopped I was overwhelmed on
that time it was like heartbreaking for
me so yeah imagine your family being in
a country that was just taken over by
the Taliban you're in another country it
was like killing me you know eight
seconds was like passing for me like two
one ear and what's communication like I
mean are you you're talking to them on
the phone like how yeah ex are you
worried WhatsApp yeah what the first
days when they just came and had take
over the country the internet was
working but just after five or four days
later they just stopped and just
decreased the internet access for the
pupils because the pupil just like
broadcast in the media what they do with
the pupils you know in the first
this when they arrived over there they
just killed thousands people thousands
you know all the an pupils all the
interpretors all the P who just uh like
against them in this past 20 years so I
was in stumble and this this incident
happened I didn't know what should I do
in this time I have no idea except just
I texted to Travis on that time yeah I
just texted him like hey dear brother
please help
me it was a wild
time yeah so I just told him to please
help my
family get out of that
hell so I you know received that message
from him on Facebook you know messenger
I get a message for him because we're
friends again on
Facebook and I'm in San Francisco at the
time I'm in the Bay Area for work and
I'm sitting around and um
you know of course I'm watching all of
this on the news and I know he's going
to reach out to me and and boom the
message comes across and and you know
I'm watching the news and you know
everybody that I work with former
military guys in the protection field
and we're all just sitting around you
know drinking beer like man can you
believe what's going on here right
now and it you know I remember watching
the news and watching them at the
airport recognizing places there in
Cobble and and seeing the Taliban and
kind of doing our own little Intel
Gathering through through sources on the
internet people we have on the ground
and I use Snapchat a lot I know that
sounds like a something like a
12-year-old would use but you know on
Snapchat you can get on these uh heat
Maps where you people can post live to
like where they're at and it's a great
source of information and I remember for
10 years or 5 10 years I'm on Snapchat
popping over into Cobble and looking
okay I don't see any Taliban anywhere
they're they're not and then when that
happened I remember popping on the
Snapchat to kind of get a live view of
what's what's outside the airport you
know the taliban's in hiding for 20
years they don't want to be known and
seen but once they took over and they're
taking over these provinces and they
make their way into Cobble now they're
not scared anymore they don't have to
hide anymore and so I remember hopping
on those heat maps and seeing them
everywhere and it was like holy [__]
yeah God and and what are the
conversations I mean like with you and
your wife I mean what is what what are
you what are you saying to her and and
what what are those conversations like
yeah I G to just explain you after I
just received a positive response from
Travis he was in uh his job you know he
he was Travis was not at home he just
told me that right now I just fly and
just like he qu you know he just quit
his job not for one day one week one
month just for more than one year just
for my family
so I I just transferred the same thing
what Travis told me for my wife so for a
woman for aan woman it was difficult to
trust especially on that situation you
know she just told me you're you crazy
and your brother that you're calling his
him brother you're crazy you both are
outside this country and you don't know
the situation what happening and my kids
my wife was so scary they were so worri
they were just waiting for killing you
know every second that somebody will
come knock the door and kill us and and
what were they doing were they and what
is her daytoday then I mean is she is
she in hiding is she what is she do yeah
yeah I tell you right now in the first
day just came here they were in my
father's home which was at the East part
of Kabal it's called car now they were
just over there in my own home the home
that I build it with my own hands you
know they were over there but I just
told them please go away from there
since I received the message from Travis
I told them my father-in-law whom it was
so close with the
airport that's why I just Evac I just
told him to relocate move from that
location to other location to your
father's home I told her this so she
just start moving from my father's home
to her father homes which was close by
the airport and uh I was just telling
the same thing what Travis told for me I
just told him told her to get
ready uh just for moving to the airport
and the first day just like uh felt in
their first attempt to get to the
airport we tried so much and uh like you
ask it about the how you convers how was
your conversation the internet was not
working at all inside I mean around the
airp Port there were so many people
crammed into there actually not only
because of the people you know the
Americans you know moo uh I just forgot
that MOA or that's kind such kind of uh
machines the Americans just turn it on
the signal the internet was not working
around the airport it was a big problem
over there at the same time I think the
Taliban also just like uh limited the
internet access for the pupil so I just
I was like calling I just made a
connection with my sister-in-law which
was at home and she was just calling to
my wife on direct line on Direct phone
then she was calling she was like
passing all the conversation of me to my
wife then from my wife to me then I just
called like transferred all the
conversation to Travis at the same time
it was like unbelievable you know wow
difficult
situation and so they just felt in their
first attempt to uh enter the airport it
was like a huge chaos you know around
the airport like I can tell you more
than 100 200 300,000 P gathered in a
very small space yeah on concrete too
you know you got concrete bottoms and
then you got concrete walls they're
called tea walls you know it's already
hot there it's August so you can imagine
the heat that's created they're like
little human ovens and the idea is what
like you gather by the airport you wait
by the airport and everybody's got
whatever documents they have who however
they're associated with Americans like
get us out and and and who's deciphering
who gets out or not I mean how you're
just waiting on paperwork from the state
department you know everybody's applying
for sivs and p2s they're called uh
online and and you know during this time
when he when he contacts me I'm in San
Francisco yeah I'm [__] pissed off
you know it's like I cannot believe that
my guy's family is still there after all
of this time you know the sacrifice he's
made we've been trying I mean you know
he he won't say it but you know he he
was there with us through everything he
when we my unit ripped out and left he
stayed with the other Marine unit was
blown up with them you know was knocked
out with them you know this guy has put
his time in and here I am sitting in a
hotel in San
Francisco safe my family safe
everything's good
you know it's just an experience for me
you know I went to the war I just you
know this is his life you know but yeah
he reached out to me and then you know I
kind of talked to a couple close people
in my circle and most of them were like
dude there's nothing you can do like you
just got to let this go and from the
outside you know now that I've talked to
those people now they were like yeah
dude you you looked rough cuz I was up
you know like I was awake I'm such a
schemer at heart you know like we're
going to make something happen you
know and yeah he contacted me and then I
was like reached out to buddies on my
team and a lot of them were like dude
there's nothing you can do let it go and
then I got one close friend was like
dude there's something we can do here
and uh you know I called my boss I said
I'm out of here you know this is what's
going on fire me I quit whatever happens
I don't care I'm out of here flew back
home to Tennessee and then pulled out my
computer you know I had two computers uh
and my you know two cell phones running
at a time just trying to gather Intel of
what's going on here trying to tap into
whatever networks okay who do I know
that's there right now because I've seen
it from the military side I've seen it
from the media side I've seen it from
the uh private security Contracting side
you know I've got contacts there I just
have to go down my Rolodex and find out
who's there and see and see who can help
us yeah and and that was the whole goal
for like uh for the next basically you
know two weeks I was trying to find
people there that were able you know
we'd find people and they're like dude
there's nothing we can do it's it's a
mess I me it's a [__] mess everybody
that has a contact over here is is doing
exactly what you're doing right now
right right yeah and so you know I'm
pulling up maps on computers and you
know during that time there's like
underground groups being created of just
guys like me former military dudes that
have contacts over there that were
trying to get these people out and so
these groups are being created and
you're slipping into them and these
group threads and you're finding
information on that solid Intel some
shitty Intel and you're taking what
whatever information's
there uh you know finding out where all
the Taliban checkpoints are and plotting
them on our maps and then developing a
plan how we're going to get his family
to the airport but you know the hardest
part was finding somebody to be able to
snatch
them you know out of a gate where
there's a 100,000 people right and get
them on a plane and to get them on a
plane yeah so I started tapping into my
network of
uh you know just who do I know out there
and I reached out to a guy that I had
protected uh in the Middle East and uh
he's kind of a big wig now and I you
know you don't reach out to people you
protect and ask for favors it's just
you're crossing a line you know but you
know at that point I was like I don't
care who it is I'm going to ask so I hit
this and we're we were friends on uh
social media and I hit him up and boom
he got right back to
me which is not you know you don't see
that uh in in government type people
you know it just they're not as helpful
as you would want them to be but man I
reached out to this dude he got back to
me and said one of my contact is one of
my contacts is in route there right now
this is his name he'll be on ground in
like 10 hours and we're going to try and
make something happen so it was like
that gave us like a glimmer uh of Hope
and so I told him what was going on and
then that's when when we started to
develop the plan and I was showing him
Maps you know here's the overhead of the
airport there's like I don't know
probably 10 different Gates that people
are coming through you know the Brits
are helping out the Canadians are over
there the us all of our allies are you
know trying to get their allies out as
well so we started develop that plan and
and just try and be
patient uh and all while this is
happening we know an attack's coming
anybody who's got a brain or any sort of
like tactical sense know that there's
going to be an attack that happens here
so you're fighting the clock you know
look how close it packed every body is
look how close they are to the military
and they know they know you've got
Americans and other Allied Forces there
you've got ex interpreters families of
everyone there is got it everybody
that's at the airport is trying to leave
Afghanistan so they're all the enemy to
the Taliban and that ticking clock for
everybody at the airport is very much
real if you don't make it out you are
going to be you're left behind yeah yeah
exactly so all you know while that's
going on we're trying to develop plan
and at one point watching the news you
know I'm watching the news some
reporters doing a piece to the camera
there and I look in the back I'm like
that's my I know this dude back there
and he he's on a gig over there with
this person wow and I reach out to him
and uh he's like doing a or the lady
that he's with is doing a live piece to
the camera and I'm like holy [__] that's
the dude that's him you know I'm not
going to say his name but he so I like
pull up my phone and I sent him a
message like I'm watching you right now
yeah yeah and it was like a glimmer of
hope you know like somebody there that I
know what's this look like out here
right now you know what's going on do
you see a good Avenue what's what what's
the best gate we could send this family
to and um but yeah it was like a glimmer
hope and I reach out and text this guy
and then there's like a delay you know
there's like a 105c delay because
they're on the other side of the world
and sure enough I see him like take a
yeah and he he's texting me back and I'm
in my hotel room probably butt naked you
know like jumping on my bed like dude
here we go you know and then once once
that
happened I that's when I told my boss
you know my team I was like I'm out of
here I'm going back to Tennessee we're
going to make something happen you know
and I hopped on a flight went back to
Tennessee and set up a little I call it
the redneck Jason Bourne operation you
know yeah and like we're going to make
something happen right here and so I got
the computers and everything set up and
you know by the time I got home that
that contact had landed on ground from
the guy that I protected his friend it
was on ground and I already had messages
like in the chamber for him to receive
as soon as he lands hey I'm a friend of
so and so he's pointed me in your
direction what can you do you know and
he responded back with you know I just
got here give me a couple hours we'll
assess the situation and what's going on
um and we'll we'll go from there so you
know be on standby be be ready to move
and at this point I mean like when
you're breaking this story down to
somebody new it's like at this point I
mean you're you're communicating mostly
through through message right it's not
voice everything's text you're you're I
mean you're you're making these appeals
yeah I mean you know exactly what to
write what are you writing I'm I'm I'm
not trying to leave any fat on what I'm
writing right right these people that
are there don't have time to don't have
time for that no here's what's going on
but they need to know this is
tremendously important they need to know
the sacrifice this the guy here's my
connection with him here's his family
this is what they look like there right
now can you help if you can't help I
don't care if you're the president of
the United States I don't want to
[__] talk I don't have time like we
are on you know Ur it's unreal and and
when you when when you're getting this
information and then you're communic
ating back because you have no line to
his I speak the language right is there
a risk every time you're communicating
with your family is there is there a
risk I mean just just that communication
that could be intercepted that's putting
them at in danger absolutely it was high
risk every seconds I was scared or worry
maybe they will just like track my
wife's food so do you have to decipher
sort of this is a message I want to pass
on or this is a message I'll wait until
I get a little bit more to give
something like I was I was like telling
to my wife to please delete every
message you're receiving from me just
delete it delete it yeah as yeah yeah
got it got it phone yeah got it as soon
as you get it got it yeah got it and she
also needed you know a lot of people are
showing up with paperwork to plead their
case you know like hey this is the
paperwork that I have please let us
through right well they're Crossing
through there's 30 Taliban checkpoints
outside the airport right now so if that
you know you're going to oh come here
who are you let me search you real quick
now I got this document yeah let's go
over here in this back alley over here
real quick you and that's what was going
on so we're did she end up uh bringing
paperwork with her that she had she did
she she I just told her to please keep
this like hiding the paperwork that
Travis sent me and also I sent her in
the email then he she just like put it
all the paperworks inside her
braist
because if the Taliban search them they
will like do touch on the women's we
know this because they they didn't do
this but for the males they just search
it all around of the body so that's why
she just put it all the paperworks here
and because of the checkpoints so she's
putting that all all within her bra or
whatever but what are you telling her to
say when she goes through Taliban I mean
because if they're there they're trying
to get out like what what is she did she
go through Taliban checkpoints exactly
and they did not one many many and so
what is she saying to the Taliban yeah
actually oh I'm sorry let me just back
up a little bit here you know we knew
that it's his wife and her three small
kids and we're watching on TV and
gathering information the airport's a
wreck people are being trampled babies
are dying kids are dying and just being
thrown on seawire you know the
constantina barbwire B dead dead kids
everywhere it it is a chaos and it's
fight to get out of this
country and so I knew that his wife and
those kids aren't going to make it
through you know so we start kind of
exploring okay who can help them like
she had she had two brothers two younger
brothers that I you know I like enlisted
to help you know he had mentioned uh
them before and I was like okay this
could work and so I was giving them like
I need to see how like reliable these
people people are cuz if I tell you to
to walk and I tell you to take 15 sexs
or 15 uh steps and then stop right there
and then turn in that alley I need you
to do exactly that cuz I got a contact
walking around out here that's trying to
snatch you you need to do exactly what
I'm telling you to
do um so I was I started giving them
like little side quests you know like
hey go get a stroller um no I I told you
I said go get uh go get a go get a
wheelchair wheelchair yeah go get a
wheelchair you know and I want to put
your wife in a wheelchair so she can
hold the kids and an umbrella so she can
stay in the shade
and you know and maybe they'll take pity
on her you know you're you're just
coming up with whatever you can come up
with so they run down to the Bazar and
they come back with a stroller yeah you
know and so instead of a wheelchair it
was a stroller and at that point I
remember we shared like a little bit of
humor you know like hey you learned a
new word today you know that's called a
stroller you know and I'd send him to go
out and get uh like battery packs for
cell phones you know cuz who knows I
want you're going to stay there until
that last plane leaves we're going to
give it 100% everything that we got so
theyd come back and they proved you know
okay they're listening to me we can make
something happen and I told them to tie
like a red scarf around them so they can
be identified I told them to go out and
take a picture of everybody so I can
send it to my contact you know so we my
contact knows what these people look
like but then once they had all the
equipment and and you know gear to make
this push to the airport and water U I
re you know I reached out to my contact
said they're ready it's like all right
send them and so we sent them to a gate
called Eastgate
first and they go to the gate and I mean
it is a [__] mad house you know just
like you can Envision just thousands
upon thousands of people you know just
nut to butt this close with kids you
know just chaos every all the kids are
you know sick and tired and heat
stroking sitting out there all day and
and so his family sat out there and I
had a I actually had a contact you know
the airports like this and East Gates
like right here he left through a gate
over here and you know traversed through
Taliban checkpoints just a single guy
came out dressed like you know Afghan
went out and uh you know at that time
his family was relaying where exactly
where they're at and I was having them
take videos and pictures so then I can
relay to my contact okay this is what
you need to look for they're around this
area and I remember they were underneath
a little green uh like canopy like this
you know umbrella here and my contact
made it all the way up there to him and
identified him and saw
but there was nothing he could do you
know if he would he couldn't get through
that gate he couldn't make it through
aund you know or through tens of
thousands of people that were at
Eastgate at that time so we had to wave
it off you know and that was such a like
dude we were so close you know and his
family ended up waiting and waiting and
waiting out there and his kids you know
had heat stroke and they ended up
leaving you know they couldn't the kids
needed to get out of the Sun and so his
family ended up uh leaving and going
back home and uh just rehid hting and
it's like we're going to do it again and
at that point his wife was just
terrified you know like and again she
she's talking to two guys that are
running this operation that aren't even
in the country the country right she's
like who the [__] are these guys right
right right right right yeah I want to
like be 100% to be there you know
because my wife was alone my kids was
alone nobody was with them but it makes
it impossible it makes it more dangerous
exactly yeah but at the same time it was
more dangerous if I I couldn't go there
you know the borders were closed there
no way no flights no flights nothing
yeah yeah so it was like very difficult
for me each seconds it was like putting
me on the grave you know second by
seconds and we not only me me and Travis
you know we didn't like sleep for more
than one week day and night we just work
on this to out of to out them safely
from that
situation W so what happens what happens
next um so we're going to go round two
at the airport now Eastgate was a epic
failure and like a punch to the gut you
know I had confidence going into when
the family went to Eastgate it was like
I got a guy there like we're going to
make this happen I know Marines are
there you know which is like those are
my boys you know those are my people are
you in contact with them I'm trying real
real hard I'm up on in I'm looking at
you know they I'll freeze a frame that I
saw on the Internet or on the news of a
name tape with a unit okay that's this
unit that's there wow and then you're
just tracking and then I'm getting
online you know at night in Cobble you
know because we're there at different
times you know so while Afghan you know
while cbo's sleeping and the airport's
shut down I'm back home here trying to
collect Intel okay make a plan on what's
going on and then when when Cobble wakes
up everybody's back to trying to go to
the airport well I can't sleep cuz I'm
in contact with my uh with my contact
who's trying to you know you got to be
like on your toes cuz once this dude
says go you got to go yeah so you want
to miss that because you're at [__]
Hardies or taking a nap exctly and you
know during that whole time we're I'm
making contingency plan after
contingency plan I'm I'm I'm zooming the
map out looking at the overhead okay I'm
I'm reaching out to Redneck buddies back
in Tennessee that are good at driving
dirt bikes it's like hey I know you're a
crazy [__] would you be willing to fly
in say India with me we cross into
Pakistan and then we go in the Border
acquire a car we're going to get this
dude's family out right right and of
course that dude's like whatever man
let's go yeah whose car are we taking
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we're making all
plans you know just every plan that you
could make yeah um and just scared out
of your mind the whole time you know I
never had I've never had that kind of
pressure on me before sure this isn't
just some random dude who reached out to
me this is my interpreter's family you
know and I had never met his kids but
once he starts sending me pictures of
his kids man it's
like dude you fall in love with them
immediately immediately you're like I
know these kids I've never met him but
his little son looks just like him we're
going to get these dudes out yeah yeah
yeah yeah and now you're on Mission I
mean this is this is but dude the amount
of pressure that was on you know I'm
sitting at home in Tennessee in front of
some computers and I got a little golf
cart I drive around I live on the river
I got four acres and I'm riding around
in my golf cart with my headphones in
waiting for calls from contacts texting
him
strategizing in my brain and my
neighbors you know they're all like what
the hell is this dude doing out here
yeah and you know my wife she was my
girlfriend at the time but you know from
I think from an outsider's perspective
it looked like I was having a PTSD
meltdown and I don't blame him for that
yeah um but there's no time to walk
there no time to even have that
conversation right right there's no time
right clock is literally ticking right
now right um so that you know as the um
the days progress it's like okay we're
going to make another run on this gate
and my contact reach out to me and and
you know he's like I think Abby gate is
going to be the our best bet let's try
and get him through abig gate and I
agreed with him you know I'd seen the
overhead maps and and other video that
I've obtained from that gate it's the
best place to get grabbed from the crowd
you know the Marines have an extension
out there there's like a big road that
comes across and all the Afghans are
lined up on this road and then here's
your entrance into the airport that's
where everybody's trying to get to so
there's just thousands of people packed
in here and then there's the sewage
canal and then there's all the Marines
that are lined up and other government
entities that are there maintaining
security make sure nobody jumps over the
walls and the right people are coming
through uh so my contact reach out to me
and says Abby Gates it we're going to do
it at this time get your family ready so
reached out to him like hey make sure
your kids are hydrating eating food
convince your wife to to go you know
because at this point she's like no I'm
not doing it you know and I'm like
listen lady I've never met you but just
trust in you know our process right now
I know your husband we know what we're
doing here we're pretty
crafty and she was like no yeah because
she she afraid she was like afraid she
scared especially because of my children
you know each each seconds every minutes
was like a possib there was possibility
or chance of their de
I mean in the middle of that crowd that
chaos right because of that she was so
afraid and said no I I don't want to go
back to that airport to that situation
right and they're sending pictures of
these just horrid conditions you know
there's there's a picture that really
struck home with me with his oldest
daughter uh that was sent to you know
Ram from his wife had sent this picture
and sent it to me and it's a picture of
his oldest daughter uh just laying you
know sitting up and kind of leaning On A
Suitcase sitting on top of human feces
Oh my God you know and it was like no
child deserves to go through through
this let alone my boys yeah [__] that
kid yeah you know and it was just like
man and there was a lot of times where
there was no hope in that you know it's
like we're going to try everything we
can but I don't think this is going to
work you know there's a lot of doubt
that you're battling and facing
sure but anyway the
my contact reaches out to me and says
hey we're going to make another run at
this get your family ready give me an
updated picture of them so you know they
whatever clothes they changed into I had
them go out and take another picture of
them tie the red bandanas on get the
kids in the stroller bring water bring
your battery
chargers uh I don't know if they had an
umbrella I think I told them to grab an
umbrella for shade they still have those
umbrellas yeah yeah I need that
umbrella uh but yeah so they they went
to the to the gate and it and it was a
mad house because again the clock's
ticking you know all the whole world
knows that that last flight out of there
I wish I had the date in front of me I
should know it it was like August 27th
something like that was the red line you
know that the Taliban Drew Taliban said
we've negotiated how far away how far
away are you from that date at this
point it was the 2 24th 24th a matter of
days yeah two days we're close and we've
been at it for two weeks you know I've
been telling this dude to be patient for
two weeks trust me trust in this process
convince your wife to go that's your
only
job um but so my again my contact
reaches out to me and says get the
family ready and I'm you know just
through the roof like here we go um and
so instead of texting him you know
because we usually I called him directly
and I was like hey my contact's there
this is what's going on and he's like
there's like humor in this he's like
brother this is Taliban trick no we
can't do this this you know he's like
everybody's being told there's a contact
there and to go to the airport right now
it's this is a Taliban trick we're not
doing this and I was like if you've ever
listened to me in your life like you're
going to do exactly what I'm telling you
to do right now you remember that yeah
yeah exactly so I convinced him and
thank God he convinced his wife and they
loaded up and uh went to the airport and
you know the whole time this is going on
I'm in direct contact with my guy at the
airport who's outside of a gate and he's
got his guys his operators and he's put
push outside the wire to look for these
guys and I'm relaying positions where
they're at at all times um and one thing
we're battling that whole time is cell
phone service you know CU we finally
made it all the way up there to this
gate and now they don't have cell phone
service and now I can't relay exactly
where they're at
yeah and it's like horrifying you know
because they've came so close and now we
we you know they're not going to be able
to find them and and we we went through
shitty uh cell phone service that whole
day and finally they they get to the
airport my contact sends his guys
out and they end up spotting uh one of
the
brothers and uh Flags him down and it
was just like a and my my contact sends
me hey we've got eyes on them and it was
just like unbelievable that this just I
mean it's finding a needle in a hay
stack with all these
people because you know you got to
understand with the amount of people
that's in here I mean just picture going
to Metallica concert with all these
lunatics and trying to make your way up
to the front row it's not going to
happen right right everyone's trying to
get everybody no one cares it's not just
to see [__] Lars [__] play the
drums it's like life is life is thatat
gate yeah yes and and people are willing
to do anything because they're they're
in the same situation because they've
got kids too right and you you it ain't
happening from the middle like you know
like it's only happening at the front
yeah and so we we got them position I'm
telling them to get up in here and you
know get in get in the crowd and I think
at one point she was attacked yeah she
backed off and like no I'm not she got
cold feet no I'm not going to sit here
and watch my kids get trampled to death
it's not happening and and I remember
being so selfishly [__] mad at her
you know looking back at it it's like
you know while it was happening I was
like well she just needs to listen to me
and and and even back when I told them
to leave the house okay leave the house
right now you my contact wants you there
you're going to leave the house right
now and I remember them taking a long
time to leave and I remember messaging
him like ROM I told you to have your
family you know ready to go at a
moment's notice and leave and it took
like 10 15 minutes and you know looking
back at it dude she's saying goodbye to
her entire family that she'll never
probably ever see again nieces nephews
brothers sisters mothers fathers a whole
life and here I am some American sitting
in a golf cart in Tennessee telling her
to hurry you know for a good reason yes
sure but you know I look back at that
and it's like man it kind of like shows
you like the different perspectives you
know we think the answer is oh just do
it fast or do this and it's like dally
from a grunt's perspective right like
you're used to being the grunt on the
ground now you're the general calling
the shots yeah yeah yeah anyway so they
fast forward back to Abby you know they
they make it to Abby
gate and they they start to position
through the crowd and you know they
start to encounter you know some rough
stuff getting you know she's getting
beat up pushed around so she pulls out
and you know R's like no she's done
right you remember that yeah yeah I was
so scared on that time when she just
attacked by the crowd peoples on that
and she just Li down on the ground and
uh I was like thinking that she will be
die like this you how how how how old
are the kids at this
point uh my twins was like uh two and a
half yeah and my older daughter was six
so so she she's holding the the yeah
exactly yeah yeah she holding the two
kids the Twins and then the six-year-old
is what just holding on to her sure cuz
I think she pushed them she pushed them
in the stroller or they got them in the
stroller as far as they could they
gotoll yeah strollers got to go whatever
rest of pupil didn't let you go of
course for of course and the brothers
are just doing what they can because
everybody wants to leave of course of
course there was no priority right right
right right I mean this yeah
yeah and so they you know they you know
Rah convinces her hey you got to try it
again and I remember messaging him like
this is your shot at Freedom right now
this is the chance for your children to
live a life that you know that you could
have never
imagined uh and Rah convinced her and
he's agreed okay we're going to try it
again and sure enough they go back in
there to try again that's when the one
of the operators comes out sees them and
then calls them over and they kind of
got to go through the crowd and the
crowd kind of parts the ways a little
bit cuz they see a guy you know motion
them for him to come here and they uh
they cross that you remember cuz all the
Afghans are here there's a giant sewage
canal in the middle and then that's
where all the Marines are on the other
side and so they swim across the sewage
canal with the the kids above their
heads and uh hand them up to those
dudes and they you know snatch those
kids up and then that my contact reaches
out to me hey we got them oh dude when I
heard that you know when I think back on
this whole story I I don't have memories
I mean I've got a I knew I was riding
around in my golf cart pacing around
like a lunatic in my yard but when I
think back to that two weeks we were
doing this like I struggle with figuring
out where I was when I found out that
information cuz when I flash back to
that time like I'm there with them my
memories are in at abig gate with them
my memories are at their house or in a
taxi outside the airport you know
because I'm familiar with all of those
areas but man when they swam across with
the kids above their heads and handed
them up to those dudes and you know they
snatched those kids up and my contact
you know was like we got them you know
dude I just [__] collapsed on the
ground I
mean it was
Unreal and then you know obviously relay
that to him you
know what' you think about it when you
yeah it was it was I can say like the
best moment of my life when I just
received a message from Travis that he
told me my contacts got your family no
worry at all they just made to enter to
the airport right
now it was the best moment I can say
yeah and I was so lucky and just my
tears came I couldn't like
stop
yeah you know regardless a paperwork you
know cuz the immigration's just a
nightmare to get but and they're still
not US citizens but when they cross that
sewage canal and those Americans touched
them they they're [__] Americans
right then and it's the coolest thing
that the Marines have ability to do you
know we can touch somebody and you're
now one of us forever and your kids are
going to live a great life now you know
I get goosebumps talking about it I mean
it was just the
craziest roller coaster of emotions
you know I I don't
know what would have happened if if we
were UNS unsuccessful with that CU they
they took those
kids and then they you know made them
walk and then they threw them in a up
armored Land Cruiser and drove them out
to the flight line and they went into a
building and okay verified who they were
and then I confirmed with my contact hey
what flight are you putting these these
guys on because at that point it's not
they're not just sending 100,000 people
to the US right there's countries
opening up their borders all over like
not great countries right you know we're
talking third world countries over in
Africa right that are like uh you're
going to give us how much money to take
these people right okay yeah bring them
and let them sit in the desert and we'll
give them some water right and that was
also a big fear you know we don't want
to have them end up in a country like
that right right where we kind of you
know we lose contact with them because
there's no cell phone service like right
this is you're you're realizing this is
an a massive hurdle you just got over
but you're not there yet not there yet
no and uh my contact who the greatest
contact you could ever have I wish I
could reveal who this dude is uh but he
doesn't want to be named you know I
understand that I I don't I'm not I'm
not interested in that I I but that
being said I guess the one thing that
I'm was your contact there because I
hearing this story and trying to put
myself in both of your
shoes I would imagine like the hard the
hardest thing is to keep motivating this
Conta like at any point you feel like
you're going to burn him out right and
like at some and like what is the
contact doing there like what is like is
the contact doing specifically this yeah
he's he's there on behalf of the of the
government assigned a certain task from
DC to go in there and do a certain thing
understood but like I correct me if I'm
wrong I I imagine the
context job that day or job being there
is not getting certain people out is
that what he's specifically supposed to
be doing there no I don't I I think he
was there to assist in that process but
you know you know I made it clear to
relay to these my contact and both my
contacts that set this up like this is a
dude that isn't just some random Afghan
dude this is a dude who was on the front
lines with us has carried my dead dudes
around to helicopters who's carried gear
for us and he's done everything we could
ask and I was be sure to you know I was
sending them pictures too like here's a
picture with me and this dude back in
Maria in 2010 like this is who this dude
is right and also letting those dudes
know and kind of putting the heat on hey
if you don't make this happen my ass is
going in there mhm and I know you don't
want that mhm you know it doesn't look
good on you guys right but that I wanted
to I didn't you know I wasn't talking to
him roughly like that but I wanted him
them to know that but it is it's such a
it's such a crazy thing to navigate
because it's like your wife everybody
has got to you you know sort of achieve
this this impossible goal but at any
point you know if she if she said look I
just can't do it or like hey look man my
hands are like we tried like there's so
many chances of failure absolutely
absolutely and you're just the whole
time you're just you're just praying to
to for it to
work can you talk about getting eyes on
them for the first time well I had him
send uh I was like send me a picture of
them like I want to see a picture of
these you know in the airport and uh you
know my contact sends me the
picture and again just boohoo crying you
know thought I was tough you know cuz
I'd been to Maria back in 2010 hadn't
shed many tears and here I am just you
know in my sun room at my house just
crying and S relaying him these pictures
and also relaying it to other friends uh
that knew what was going on other
marines that we were with other army
guys that he knows and they're all
crying too and you know it's just
unbelievable
and and I also had to confirm hey where
is the plane going that you're sending
them cuz now I'm right back on to okay I
got another I got another thing here you
know this is we don't want this to
roller coaster or start spiraling into
another problem that we've got to solve
I want them on a flight to the USA sure
and you know once he got them in that
building and verified who they were and
sent me that picture and then I said
okay where's the flight going and he's
like USA it was just
like let's go
baby and uh and they they went you know
they walked them out to the flight line
and there's a bunch of Afghans piling on
I mean they're cramming these uh these
planes for these transport planes um and
you know they they they take off and he
sent me pictures of them walking out
there and getting on the getting on the
bird and taking off and
leaving and uh they ended up going to uh
where' they go cutter yeah yeah they
went to dohaqatar uh where there was
like a little staging area for refugees
coming in and uh like processing uh
facilities and you know
not I want to say it was like six or
seven hours after that happened we got
them out and that family was snatched
out by those guys and brought in and
gone their lives are changed forever a
suicide vest came in and blew up and
killed 13 or killed 12 Marines one Army
soldier um and the death toll of the
Afghans that was at that gate it's over
100 and
climbing right there and you know we'll
never know exactly sure we'll never know
exactly for 100% sure if those were the
guys that snatched our family out but I
would say there's a good good chance
that it was those dudes God bless him
yeah
unreal you know how close that his
family was to being right there because
it was right there within feet of where
they were at you know and to see that
hit the news and it was just at that
point you know you're waking up after
finally okay family slate or uh family
safe they're on a flight let me try I
have to sleep my body's going to shut
down and then waking up and seeing that
on the news you remember that ROM yeah
yeah when did you get to hold him for
the first time touch him for the first
time and cut her oh no it was it was the
difficult time you know when you are
being like separated from your kids and
your families I was just like waiting
for the paperwork process even it was
not on that time started my paperwork
when my family just got to the Catal you
know because me and Travis was didn't
think for myself on that time just for
my family you
know so I was waiting just for like one
year or more like this you know held up
in Turkey waiting on paperwork wow to
get to America exactly even even with
your service exactly exactly yeah
totally I can say it it was like more
than one decade you know like 12 years
waiting for this you know but especially
in this perod I just left my kids like I
said for you they were 2 and a half
years old so I saw and huged them when
they were four years old
wow for three two and a half years I was
away from them yeah separated from him
yeah you know he he left Cobble because
the USA wasn't taken you know it's like
you can't come here so R's like Roger
that let's keep the ball rolling I'm
going to get my family out somehow so
turkey accepted him and he did
everything he was supposed to do over
there get the Visas and he you obtained
the Visas right he obtained the Visas
and sent them back to Cabell to the
Turkish Embassy and that's when kabble
was taken over and all of those
embassies evacuated wow so if they would
have had the Turkish passports they
could have left they could wow but it
was that was and their passports was
inside the EMB Turkish Embassy on that
time wow yeah
wow wow yeah so it was more difficult
for me on that time and I like you ask
it when you just huged him just like
after two and a half years and that was
and that was that was State
side yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah what
was that like uh it was like December
2022 uhhuh yeah yeah when I I think it
was the 24th right or 23rd day before
Christmas Eve yeah 23rd December 22 I
just got here finally yeah yeah and it
was good moment as well you know when I
just hear from USCIS you know it was it
was this paperwork was like for me going
from Hell To Paradise I was waiting like
this you know because I was messing from
my kids you know yeah every time when I
just called to my daughter to my oldest
one she was saying why you're not coming
where are you everyone has that but not
me
so it happened for me and it was like a
you
know like there is a power above as
above me above my family just watching
as you know it was happened the same
gate that when I just start working with
the Marines my family just left at the
same gate to the
US the same the same G where I just
start working with the Marines back in
2010 I just flew from the same gate to
the Maria yeah when he got that
interpreter job when he back in 2010
when he became the you know okay you're
an interpreter you're going to go to
Maria go to the airport and go to go to
abig gate that's where you're going to
find your helicopter yeah yeah wow they
just evacuated from the same gate wow
yeah yeah wow
that's but you know that's a that was a
whole another battle getting him here
cuz he's stuck in turkey and
unfortunately he's not the priority
it's it's getting women and children and
all these people out and he sat in in
refugee camps for how long was it total
was like a year and a half yeah it was
here yeah total yeah yeah so he went
from you know do he went from Turkey
linked him up with some contacts there
sent him to the refugee camp in Doha it
was taken forever there you know all the
background investigations that take
place and and and for good reason for
sure and and Rah agrees too I mean it
was a pain in the ass and we were
disappointed that it wasn't expedited
but we both agree for good reason for
sure it's price of freedom for sure uh
and they sent him to Kosovo where there
was another uh base there what was that
camp called uh It
was Leah Camp Leah it was named after if
I'm not mistaken it was named after a
baby that was born an Afghan baby that
was born exactly on an evacuated uh on a
flight that that left so they named this
camp Camp Le I hope I'm getting that
right I'm pretty sure that's wow yeah
you know while while this is going on
and you're going to COA where where's
your family well they they got sent to
go ahead yeah my family got here just
like one year like before I just start
my paperwork started I just start moving
from Turkey to C then to Kosovo right
they just got here and they're in where
are they they're they landed in a place
called Fort picket in Virginia which is
like an an army holding uh base um for
ref processing refugees cuz it was such
a fast thing nobody was processed
leaving there so now we've got a little
time we're going to actually process who
these people are and really dig into who
they are um so they sat there for what
two months right no for more than three
months three months yeah they were over
there for forther processing of the
paperworks of the like medical exam
examination everything like this and
and your your wife emotionally like how
is she happy to be there is she sad to
like
yeah and the first and the first when
they just evacuated on the aircraft in
military it was the first time for a
woman with the thousands of people like
maybe more than like thousand you know
in a one aircraft they just gathered to
each other you know there was no other
privacy to some men just touch you
around your back or around your hands or
in your legs lamps like this so for her
it was so difficult I bet very difficult
and also you know she didn't wash her
body her feet for more than two days
from from going through thew all the
shades all the dirs from the sewage
canel when she just crossed that it was
just inside at her body wow yeah and she
just like had very like a bad smell and
so when they just got catcher and after
that they just got to hear and for pet
when I was talking with her she had a
good feeling yeah and she was so happy
and she didn't care about anything on
the past she was just thinking for the
future especially for my kids for our
kids yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
beautiful and when that was you know was
going on it was like these people R I
don't care what you say your family's
coming to live at my house got nowhere
to go yeah yeah uh I'll be damn if we're
going to make it this far right and you
get thrown in a dangerous neighborhood
somewhere cuz that's that's what happens
is a lot of refugees end up going to the
inner cities of these places number one
where it's dangerous number two where
it's they can't afford this they've left
everything behind they don't have credit
they don't and you're going to send them
to go live in this other war zone right
so I was like absolutely not so I I
rally my little uh Town together and you
know we collect donations I mean at the
drop of a hat I got a my wife's friends
you know they at the drop of a hat man
they had beds clothes wow go down the
list of anything these people would need
I mean it was like overnight it was
appeared in our
house yeah it it was awesome so you had
the family there with you before he got
there yeah yeah and and and what was
that like unbelievable I mean you know
it took forever once they got to Fort
picket uh the the army base for
processing was it was it two months they
were there three months three months
yeah so they just wa and you can imagine
after everything I've been through I
still haven't met these people people
we're preparing for them to to get here
I don't have a job this is my job now
until Rah gets here right right and is
your girlfriend now your wife yeah and
and is she excited about yeah this must
have been crazy it was interesting to
see CU you know I know Afghans and I've
traveled the world you know she at that
point she hadn't really you know so
she's asking like you know do they speak
English like do I have to wear a hijab
like I'm like
no but it was interesting to see that
that Clash of uh bet C I bet CU it was
like her she's a labor and delivery
nurse so she she meets you know people
who speak different languages you know
to have somebody like that live in your
house oh yeah yeah it was interesting
interesting to to see but yeah we
finally got the call from Fort picket
hey uh these people say that they're
going to come live with you are you on
board with that I'm like let's go uh put
them on a plane and they flew them uh
into Knoxville and um my wife me and my
wife were hanging out waiting on them
and then I got a tracking device on the
on the plane you know I know exactly
where they're at and they land like here
they come and then here you know here
they come through through security and
you know it was like they went from
people just that I just saw pictures of
to like I'm now holding my interpreter's
kids wow you know it's
just the most it's so powerful you know
it is so
powerful you know that's the realities
of War you know that's yeah sure you
know
military people they get out and they
have issues and this and that but you
know dude this is those are the ones are
the most affected you know these kids
you know these kids would have never
gone to school especially the two girls
they would have never gone to school you
know they would have just lived under
Darkness like like Rah says yeah um but
to have them show up and man we it was
like I knew them you know and I felt
that you know from them too you know it
was like oh this is that crazy
[__] yeah cuz you remember you know in
the beginning of the story his wife's
like I don't know your crazy friend like
who is this dude he's in Tennessee but
yeah when they showed up it was just we
swooped them up and then uh you know we
had been collecting donations and I put
the word out in my little you know
southern town which I also want to point
out and a lot of people have asked me
this you know the South has such a
stigma for being racist and yeah yeah
you know we don't like people that
aren't white
rednecks that is such [__] yeah yeah
absolutely and I feel it necessary to
like clear that air for other people to
hear and a lot of times it's people from
that aren't even from the south that are
making this assumptions you know but
we're all poor down south together you
know and my little town came together
and blew it out of the water you know
these kids showed up but they didn't
have social security numbers yet they
didn't have you know they were missing
so many documents and things that were
required for them to attend schools
um but you know before those kids showed
up I went to the local school system
where me and my wife went to school you
know just a tiny little town kids that
we went to school with are now teachers
and administrators and so it was cool to
walk in there and like hey guys we don't
have kids because I don't we don't have
kids uh I don't know what this is about
being you know like a parent here I
don't know what to do but I know I got
three kids inbound here yeah and I don't
know when exactly they're going to be
here but the dad over here wants them
going to school like right away that's
right you know immediately that's right
which is real cool on him yep and so we
lined it up with those administrators
and
um I remember when we got word finally
uh from Fort picket that you know
they're coming to Tennessee everything
is ready the green light let's go you
know the day before they came I went
into that school and I went into this
like uh administrator's office building
and it's all just a bunch you know it's
all a bunch of women and I I walk in
there and I dude I didn't have the words
to even tell them that okay the family's
here like I walked in there and couldn't
even speak you know just cried my eyes
out and they knew what was going on you
know and while I'm sitting there just
crying like a [__] they're like lining
up paperwork in front of me you know
these little I'm just sign over here
baby yeah come on just it's going to be
okay just sign here hey they going to be
here it's all right you know and I'm
just crying my eyes out and you know
hugged everybody and thanked them and
man Our Town rallied around these people
and I'm so proud of those people I'm so
unbelievably proud because they moved
faster than people you know I'm talking
to people in the White House when this
is going on I've got contacts everywhere
not that I'm just like some highspeed
dude but you know when you when you do
this work you meet a lot of people and
those women in that that school district
in my town moved 10 times faster than
any government entity could have even
thought to do because it was the right
thing to do and I'm so proud of them for
that that's beautiful yeah so they
showed up we picked them up at the
airport and brought them back to the
house and man I got two little two and a
halfy old twins I got a six-year-old
girl nobody speaks English his wife
speaks a little bit of English uh the
two brothers spoke a little bit of
English and it was just you know because
we're used to living that quiet life you
know we don't have kids we're hanging
out here on the river my biggest concern
is like when am I going to mow like when
is it when is it going to rain cuz I got
to get out there and moow and weedy and
it went from
like we got a house full of Afghans here
you know yeah it wild dude but so cool
to you
know they're riding around on my
lawnmower you know with me like they're
loving it they're like yeah let's go so
awesome but it was it was so interesting
to see like the language you know they
didn't speak in any English and now
they're full-blown wow can speak all the
English they how long they been here
just two years two years two years two
years yeah same mon August but that time
was really hard CU he's still stuck sure
in Turkey sure you know and my bank
account's dwindling it's like I'm not a
rich guy like and I also told him like
Hey I'm I'm not leaving until your
family is in a stable
environment and uh but yeah the
donations just poured in you know
somebody donated there was a great
couple out of Knoxville that donated uh
they they didn't been involved with
refugees in the past and and this this
great woman um uh donated she knew she
wasn't going to be around that much
longer and she donated a a Suburban
older Suburban but it was in great shape
and I mean it was just true Southern
Hospitality coming together to bring
these people in and to make it
happen I love this story so much and I'm
I'm I'm so like Blown Away by it and you
know it's all the you know story of of
of of of Brotherhood and and and family
and and and and America and fatherhood
you know and
dedication it's not normal man like I I
don't think most people would do you
know would would
would you know come I'm I'm just
wondering did you know something about
him that he's the guy that would do that
like why like how did you know that he
was that guy yeah cuz this is above and
beyond anything I've ever heard right I
mean it's
like what about him what what what made
you reach out to him
yeah I mean I just trusted on him than
myself you know we we just had that time
when we were in the mission you know we
were ready to sacrifice for each other
you know when you're ready to sacrifice
your blood for other person
so you don't need to trust to him
anymore you know the trust is nothing
you know I mean it's it's just gone you
know everything just you you do what he
says you know what what he says you you
just like believe what he says or or in
his word you know and you saw that in
combat you saw you you saw exactly who I
I I had like fully trusted on him you
know just he just said H me one word
nothing else that I help you so I just
left my family with for him you know my
family's life
everything if I didn't receive any
message from trais in any reason you
know maybe he was busy or didn't access
on the message I didn't do this I didn't
accept this
risk it was a big risk that I just
accepted this and I just lifted
everything for him and I thought that he
is doing everything that I am doing for
my family and he did he was like a
father for my children until I got there
and he did more than than me
everything's for them you guys came
together you know under under these sort
of like insane circumstances where trust
was so almost impossible to build and
and as chaotic and uh dangerous and just
as rough an environment as as possible
yet this Bond was built and it's like
you said it's um clear hold and build
you know like you saw this Mission
through yeah and and together you know
working on this like he didn't you know
I'm just like look what hearing the
story there's a million chances for this
thing to fall and there's a million
chances for you to say hey look dude I
love you call me if you need anything
but
like you quit you quit your job like you
quit you you just you literally put
everything and and then it just it kept
going you know it's like it's it's I
mean it's almost like what you said
about the south I I I I you know it's
like sometimes there's like these
misconceptions you you know I think
there's maybe misconceptions about our
our military about the the the the
strength and the the the inner the inner
honor of of the Marine Corps like I I
don't know what it is but this just does
not seem that most people would go to
the lengths that you that that you've
gone to you know had the ability to do
this you know not everybody and this is
the most non- egotistical answer to your
question but I had the ability to do
this not everybody lived the life that I
did not everybody ran off and joined the
Marine Corps and met an interpreter and
then quit doing that and then found
different jobs overseas to explore the
Middle East and you know
Afghanistan and and make contacts you
know not everybody could have made this
happen like me you know and I knew that
that I knew it was my ball to Fumble if
it didn't
happen does that make sense at all it
does I mean I gotta I mean it's not it
is not egotistical answer you know to me
it sounds like a Herculean task and it
sounds like a task that like just like
you said five minut you whatever was a
couple hours later at that same gate
look at look at what happened so it like
you're Bal to Fumble I I think I think
maybe you
know what I've learned since I was 18
years old you know from rine Corp
gunfights I s to sticky situations you
know here in the states or in another
country you know there's nobody really
coming for you except the dudes that
you're with yeah there's government
entity entities out there and
three-letter agencies that'll come pitch
in depending on what the situation is
but you
know you you got who's around you right
now and and I'm not going to be the dude
that just says no to this guy cuz
knowing ROM he's going to find a way to
come here you know he he will find a way
this dude stops at nothing and then I'm
supposed to go visit him and be like oh
yeah sorry I couldn't help you out work
was more important right right you know
right and that comes from the Marine
Corps I think you know from being a you
know in the grunts right in the Infantry
we don't
have uh the assets and and people behind
us that you know Special Operations
communities do you know they've got C130
Spectre gunships and Apaches and jets
and you know
sharks with laser beams on their
foreheads right they've got every
capability out there if we're lucky we
get some air support right if we're
lucky that that bird coming to pick up
our wounded is there in under an hour
right you got the guys next to you
that's it that's it you know and that
and I really like that though about the
Marine Corps you know especially the
grunt unit stuff in the Marine Corps
everything is so simplified like do the
task at hand if there's a building in
your way blow it up and get through it
you know there's no we're going to do
this
it's something that I've always taken
you know from the Marine Corps it's just
simplifying the task at hand and getting
it
done and and you know this dude
was he's a friend of mine you know when
I call somebody a friend of mine you
know I I take
that you know it's a big deal to me you
know I've got buddies back home that I'm
very very close with who have kids um
you know if if something ever happened
to those dudes you know bet your ass I'd
do the same thing you know and I think a
lot of people would for sure you know
but it's just they don't have the
opportunity to do that
um but man I just love this dude I don't
know what it is R he's a good-look
guy uh I'm I'm I'm just I'm I'm
enormously grateful to you both and and
bless both you and your family man it's
it's a it's a beautiful story you got um
is or anything else you guys want to
we're definitely going to as part of
this um we're going to add the GoFundMe
stuff and we're going to figure out ways
to raise money if there's anything you
guys want to say specifically about that
you could you could you could say it now
um we could also do it if you guys have
some we can just yeah you know you know
tag that long but if there's anything
else you guys feel like you want to
cover in this or anything else you want
to say you know I I'd like to say and I
I appreciate being given the opportunity
to say it you know the I I think it
looks like oh the hard part's over he's
here now his family's here they're safe
but as we know look at our economy right
now here's a guy coming over you know
being in the military I've got VA
benefits I've got health benefits you
know there's disability benefits out
there there's resources you know for
these guys coming over there's nothing
and they left everything behind banks
are frozen over there all their assets
left behind and you better believe he
was part of he he was a part of this war
and he he fought alongside exactly abs
absolutely so you know his struggle
still
continues um you know they're still
being relocated you know they still
don't have a home yet we got him an
apartment some people came together in
our town um you know the rental Market's
a disaster right now just housing in
General's ridiculous right now but you
know I'm not going to stop until I see
this guy with a key to his house and
walking in his front door and then I
think that's when I can take a break you
know but I really want to see this guy
in the house and that's what we're we're
ready money for you know he deserves it
his family deserves it they deserve some
sort of normaly and a place to call home
in and an end to this relocating you
know because they're being relocated
around nothing they they need something
permanent you know I'm tired of having
question or seeing question marks in his
eyes like well what's going to happen
this that you know they need a home and
that's what I'm that's what I'm fighting
for to get him and we'll find a way yes
you will period period yep some
something will come along where it
happens I'm I'm
positive you have any any anything else
you want to say before we
yeah like Travis it we are like right
now just struggling with this
situation uh but let me just say that I
really
grateful to him to his awesome wife you
know her name is Kelly yeah and this is
the best wife best partner for him and
for me like a
sister and uh I I also just want to
appreciate all
the community you know the pupils who
just helped my family through this time
you know they were with my family like
their family they didn't just give it
like bad feel for my family that they
from they just came from other country
you know my wife my kids just feeling
they were involved with this community
right now beautiful people people found
a way to get involved yeah they didn't
have money to donate to our you know we
were on the news and people are coming
together and donating and dropping off
items and i' you know our little town we
live we got a little grocery store
nearby and you know this little old
Appalachian woman recognizes me in the
store this is one of my favorite stories
but she's like I mean if you want to
talk to her I'd need to translate for
you you know she's just got a you know
banjos in her mouth but she uh she
walked up to me she's like little tiny
little lady hunch back she's like now I
sent you on the news yeah and I ain't
got no money but I want you she had two
rotisserie chickens she's like I want
you to take these chickens over there to
that Mama okay tell her we love her and
I you know I went to thank her y that's
it you know she just walked out you know
but but so many of those encounters like
that they're finding a way to help
that's what really like blew this out of
the water yeah that's so beautiful yeah
the the people of our town man they're
just incredible people I wish I could
hug and kiss all of them but it'd be
weird you know did did did did uh is
America what you expected exactly yeah
yes not my wife but me yeah yeah why why
not your wife yeah my wife because you
know she didn't just went away from the
my country you know she didn't have any
travel outside the country and she
didn't like have uh experience of this
kind of other pupils you know even she
just came arrive here she didn't expect
this that what Travis KY other Americans
especially Our Town people you know do
for her you know but just after two
three months she's like fall in love
with all of them you know beautiful yeah
and she's a real American right now I
can say this yeah yeah the the change in
his kids that's happened over the the
last two years is really cool CU you
know they showed up not speaking any
English and now they're starting
to
D which is really cool you know and they
get it for my wife man she she's comes
from long Appalachian Heritage you know
and she's like oh my gosh what's what's
going on what's this you know talking
like this and by BL BL and so now these
little especially his two little
daughters man they really pick pick up
on that she's there couldn't have been a
better female by my side for this I mean
she's just a beautiful woman Beautiful
Soul happy always smile on her face and
uh always doing makeup and hair and
Southern bell you know and I think those
girls really you know they were they're
that was their first taste of an
American woman is okay who's this woman
here and she she was just awesome but
yeah we're starting to see those little
Southern Accents come through that's so
awesome like she we went to the beach
and then uh we went to the beach one
time and and uh we came back and the
oldest was like key did you bring me any
seashells like all right Force Gump what
are you talking
about yeah oh it's so great but it's
such it's such a cool story it is you
know it's not just what happened the
incredible thing isn't what just what
happened in Cobble and getting them out
I mean I to me what what happened when
they came to our town is even cooler
yeah you know it's so cool to to load up
these kids and then go into this store
and I got three Afghan kids and
you know it was just it is so cool yeah
to experience that and and to load up
his kids and specifically his daughters
in the Suburban that somebody donated
and pick them up and take them to school
where me and my wife went wow and to
watch them you know I at first I'm
terrified to let him leave my side but
I'd walk them up the steps and take him
into the classrooms and then finally the
the oldest is like Travis no you stay in
the car I can walk up here yeah you know
but man you want to talk about powerful
watch watching that little Fearless girl
she was in kindergarten at the time run
up those steps yeah is just the coolest
I've done a lot of cool things but
bringing this family to to my town is
the coolest thing you could ever do yeah
it's beautiful guys I'm I'm I'm really
grateful that you you shared with us and
um just bless bless both you and your
families man it's really really cool
thank you guys yeah appreciate you
having us on thank you oh come on come
on uh I can say that uh I have not as
pressure as I had like in the preview in
the past I just feel myself my family
like uh very peaceful very like in a uh
rest uh life here uh the only thing that
I have pressure right now is only I want
just one day like in this kind of me uh
uh like uh podcast or just like this
kind of meeting my daughter you know my
daughter my kids will be sitting here
and
talk what they did you know for this
country yeah this is only my pressure
that I hope I can just like handle this
you know and I try my best for this that
my children will be proud for this
Society yeah yeah it's beautiful and
this is one of the main target for
myself for my wife we don't want
anything
else they should just grow up here and
they just serve for this for their
country yeah I remember when he landed
here sorry to keep rambling here but
when he landed uh you know I let him
stay at home for a couple days and I was
like I got to go see this dude you know
like I've been waiting for this dude to
come here since 200 you know 11 I went
and hung out with him and I was like you
need to go to the store like you need
sock shaving cream like what do you need
and so we went to Walmart of course you
know love Walmart uh but he uh he bought
two American flags wow you know and hung
them from his uh porch on his apartment
that's something that'll always stick
with me wow I love that you know this
guy has every reason to be upset about
how long it took him to get here and but
he's he's got every reason for for the
spot that that he was put in and his
kids were put in for lack of due
diligence on our government's uh you
know behalf specifically immigration
people um but he doesn't matter to him
went and bought American flags hung him
from you know his porch his kids are
spitting you know American history to me
when I come in yeah you know they're
like Travis you know how many stars are
on the uh American flag I'm like 50
they're like no no no no the old
American flag with 13 stars you know the
colonies you know I was like yeah rah's
putting in work with them yeah I love it
yeah I love it it I love it right on
well thank you guys this is this has
really been special I really appreciate
it you're most welcome appreciate you
having us on and you know being a voice
for military dudes so we appreciate you
a lot you're well known in the community
so thanks it's a real honor for real
keep doing what you're doing I'll do my
best yeah appreciate you guys thank you
guys thank
you oh man appreciate you brother
appreciate you man thank
you thank you all that made sense man it
was great you guys were it was great man
you kidding me